ja meine damen und herren wir haben
heute ja wieder eine beratung des kona
kabinetts gehabt und haben dort im
zentrum beraten wie wir die nächsten
tage angehen aber einen punkt ganz
besonders im mittelpunkt gehabt und das
war die frage der masken und
schutzausrüstung die minister altmaier
und sparen haben sie ja auch schon
informiert wir haben uns damit zu
intensiv auch als corinna kabinett
befasst weil der weltweite bedarf durch
die chorakademie sich natürlich auf
diesem gebiet vervielfacht hat und auch
noch auf längere zeit auf sehr sehr
hohem niveau bestehen bleiben wird und
deshalb sind wir in zweifacher weise
aktiv aber auch in zweifacher weise
gefordert
auf der einen seite haben wir einen
beschaffungs starb im
bundesgesundheitsministerium gegründet
der sich vor allem damit befasst
aus dem ausland die lieferungen auch zu
verstärken bzw
mehr masken nach deutschland zu bringen
die heutige produktion liegt ja vor
allem in asien 90 prozent der masken
werden in asien produziert und deshalb
haben wir uns auf diesem gebiet zu
engagieren normalerweise ist das ja
keine tätigkeit einer bundesregierung
aber in dieser außergewöhnlichen
situation ist das notwendig wir sind
auch sehr dankbar dass deutsche
unternehmen uns dabei helfen
wir haben auch natürlich auf der anderen
seite ein strategisches interesse hier
eine größere eigene zuständigkeit auch
zu bekommen und deshalb haben wir heute
darüber gesprochen dass wir einen stab
einrichten beim
bundeswirtschaftsminister der sich damit
befasst inländische produktion von
schutzhütten und schutzeinrichtungen
aber insbesondere auch masken
anzukurbeln
die vorarbeiten sind hier schon im
gesundheitssystem gelaufen
es gibt ein interesse der deutschen
wirtschaft hier auch eigene kapazitäten
aufzubauen
wir wollen das auch im europäischen
verbund machen denn dieses thema stellt
sich in allen europäischen ländern und
wir denken das ist einer der bereiche
ist in denen wir auch eine größere
strategische unabhängigkeit als
europäische union und auch als
bundesrepublik deutschland hier wieder
erreichen müssen wir haben natürlich
auch uns über die aktuelle lage
informieren lassen und können sagen die
neuesten entwicklungen der zahlen über
die ausbreitung des virus geben anlass
zu vorsichtiger hoffnung der anstieg
flacht sich leicht ab und die zahl der
aktuell infizierten geht ein wenig
zurück wenn man die schon wieder
gesundeten abzieht und leider eben auch
die die ihr leben verloren haben durch
diese pandemie will noch einmal daran
erinnern wenn das am tag 200 oder mehr
menschen sind dann sind das einfach doch
zahlen die uns nicht kalt lassen können
denn dahinter steckt jeweils ein
menschliches schicksal eine familie
angehörige freunde die trauern wenn ich
das jetzt so benennen kann dann will ich
nicht verhehlen das sage ich jetzt
gerade noch mal vor ostern dass ich zu
beginn vor noch gar nicht so langer zeit
oft besorgt war bei dem sehr schnellen
anstieg den wir gesehen haben ob wir
unsere maßnahmen nicht vielleicht noch
verschärfen müssen ob das was wir
vereinbart haben ausreicht oder ob es
uns so geht wie in einigen unserer
nachbarländer dass man noch einmal
verschärften maßnahmen einsetzen muss
und deshalb sage ich dass wir darüber
schon sehr froh sein können dass das
vielleicht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann
man das sagen nicht notwendig ist und
deshalb bedeutet das aber andersherum
auch wir dürfen uns nicht in sicherheit
wiegen sondern müssen wirklich froh sein
dass deutlichere einschränkung um
vielleicht nicht notwendig sind und das
heißt für mich wir dürfen jetzt nicht
leichtsinnig sein
wir dürfen uns nicht in sicherheit
wiegen und ich kenne das auch von mir
persönlich man hat ein bisschen hoffnung
dann gewinnt man zutrauen dann ist man
innerlich etwas entspannter und schon
ist man auch ein bisschen leichtsinnig
nein wir müssen konzentriert bleiben die
lage ist fragil
der chef des robert koch instituts hat
gerade wieder gesagt es gibt keinen
grund für entspannung und wir müssen
dies über ostern über die tage danach
weiter so fortsetzen denn wir können uns
sehr sehr schnell das zerstören was wir
jetzt erreicht haben das heißt also
konzentration disziplin das ist das was
fürsorge für die nächsten ist fürsorge
für die nächsten durch abstand und das
bedeutet dann eben auch dass dieses
osterfest ganz anders sein wird als wir
es immer in unserem leben kanten und es
wird sicherlich für viele familien für
viele menschen eine große
herausforderung sein
hinzu kommt ein fast deutschlandweit
schönes wetter was natürlich noch einmal
verlockt und deshalb meinen dank an all
die die die bestimmungen einhalten und
meine bitte an alle die es auch noch
fortzusetzen
und ich will ausdrücklich vor dem gefühl
waren wir könnten vielleicht
glimpflicher davonkommen als andere oder
als wir dachten ja der trend ist da dass
wir etwas besser da stehen heute die
verdopplung zeiten sich auch natürlich
verlangsamt haben mehr tage dazwischen
liegen ganz im gegensatz zu den ersten
tagen aber wenn wir dann überlegen wie
kommen wir in eine nächste phase
dann gehen wir wieder in ein gebiet wo
wir ja nicht wissen wie lockerungen
unserer maßnahmen wirken würden
deshalb müssen wir das auch festem grund
tun und deshalb auch der appell weiter
an die maßnahmen sich zu halten und die
klare ansage dass wir noch auf längere
zeit in und mit dieser pandemie leben
müssen
deshalb müssen wir ganz ganz vorsichtig
vorgehen wenn dann in kleinen schritten
und immer wieder die folgen beobachten
denn unser ziel bleibt ja unser
gesundheitssystem an keinem punkt zu
überfordern und allen menschen die
gesundheits behandlung zukommen zu
lassen die ihnen notwendig ist
nächste woche wird dann eine woche
natürlich wichtiger beratung seien es
haben sich in den letzten tagen schon
viele studien ergeben und viele studien
sind veröffentlicht worden die sich mit
der frage beschäftigen was können
schritte hin zu einer lockerung seien
für mich eine sehr wichtige studie wird
die der nationalen akademie der
wissenschaften sein der leopoldina die
am montag beziehungsweise dienstag
veröffentlicht werden soll über die
frage wie können wir weiter vorgehen
wenn die experten und sagen dass wir auf
festem grund stehen was die verbesserung
der infizierten zahlen anbelangt und an
dieser studie sind dann natürlich nicht
nur virologen beteiligt und
epidemiologen sondern
wirtschaftsexperten soziologen ethiker
also menschen die das gesamte
gesellschaftliche leben im blick haben
und damit auch die richtigen abwägungen
treffen können und auf dieser grundlage
und auf der grundlage aller diskussionen
die es gibt und die ja auch stattfinden
werde ich dann am mittwoch mit den
regierungschefs und chefinnen der
bundesländer beraten die bundesregierung
40 vorher am dienstag schon wieder zum
corona kabinett zusammenschalten und ich
bin dann sehr gespannt auf unsere
beratungen wir haben immer sehr gut
jetzt in kontakt gestanden sehr eng mit
den ministerpräsidenten zusammen
gearbeitet das ist auch die
voraussetzung dafür dass wir das alles
so gemeinsam miteinander bewältigen und
dann werden wir sie natürlich über
unsere möglichen entscheidungen auch
informieren
bis dahin möchte ich mich noch einmal an
alle bürgerinnen
und bürger also an uns alle wenn wir
haben in den letzten wochen gemeinsam
viel kraft bewiesen und jetzt kommt es
gerade vor diesem osterwochenende darauf
an darin nicht nachzulassen
es gilt unverändert sie schützen all die
menschen für die das virus eine tödliche
gefahr bedeuten kann
sie schützen unser gesundheitssystem in
dem sie abstand halten
und indem sie kontakte minimieren damit
meine ich alle uns alle in deutschland
ohne ausnahme wir müssen konsequent
bleiben durchhalten und wir können dann
das haben die letzten tage allerdings
auch gezeigt das land gegen das virus
verteidigen und diese schwere prüfung
die noch eine ganze weile anhalten wird
in unterschiedlicher form ich dann auch
bis zum ende bestehen
herzlichen dank frau bundeskanzlerin ich
würde zu einem aspekt der beschaffung
ganz gerne nachfragen
deutschland bekommt jetzt sehr sehr
viele schutzmasken aus china 40
millionen allein in dieser woche in der
vergangenen wochen waren es auch 40
millionen woher kommt diese veränderte
haltung einige führen das auf ihr
gespräch mit dem chinesischen
präsidenten zurück oder können sie uns
eine erklärung geben wieso china jetzt
besonders gewillt zu sein scheint
deutschland zu beliefern
da kam naja es ist einfach so dass auf
der einen seite wir natürlich auch
gespräche geführt haben das ist richtig
aber in china gibt es ja auch eine
vielzahl von privat wirtschaftenden
unternehmen und der andrang des der
vieler länder auf der welt solche masken
zu erwerben ist groß und deshalb muss
man hier auch mit professionellen
einkaufsstrategien vorgehen und soll man
die klassische beschaffung wie wir sie
aus der bundesregierung kennen mit dem
langsamen bezahlen von rechnungen
umtauschen in andere währungen und alle
diese vorgänge die gehen im augenblick
relativ schlecht das heißt man muss hier
auch sich dem der marktlage anpassen und
deshalb haben wir diesen beschaffungs
starb gegründet auch mit expertise von
menschen die etwas von einkauf verstehen
und die in fremden in fremden währungen
auch arbeiten und ich glaube die summe
der verschiedenen dinge also politischer
kontakte aber auch des managements
dieses einkaufs vorgangs im blick auf
die wirklich den großen druck auf die
produzenten in weil die nachfrage
einfach sehr hoch ist das hat zu einer
besseren belieferung auch geführt frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben gesagt man
müsse sich darauf einstellen dass die
belastung noch weiter anhalten und man
mit der pandemie leben müsse müssen sich
denn die schüler in deutschland darauf
einstellen dass womöglich die
schulferien verschoben werden und die
menschen in deutschland darauf dass der
sommerurlaub ausfällt und mit blick auf
die beratungen heute in der euro gruppe
befürchten sie dass an mangelnder
solidarität möglicherweise europa
zerfallen könnte
danke nein ich arbeite dafür dass europa
sehr viel solidarität erfährt und
deutschland wird seinen beitrag dazu
leisten
ich habe neulich schon gesagt europa
befindet sich in sicherlich einer der
schwierigsten oder der schwierigsten
bewährungsprobe weil uns alle
gleichermaßen diese pandemie zusetzt
weil wir schwere wirtschaftliche
einbrüche erleiden werden das sagen uns
ja auch alle prognosen und darauf müssen
wir gemeinsam reagieren das ist ganz
klar ich habe es eben auch am beispiel
der strategischen fähigkeiten zum
beispiel für schutzausrüstungen gesagt
ich würde das nie allein auf ein land
nur konzentrieren und ich glaube dass
die instrumente die jetzt dort in der
euro gruppe diskutiert werden und von
denen ich hoffe dass sie heute auch
beschlossen werden können nämlich einmal
prix courage maryline also ein vorsorge
programm im rahmen des esm eine
erweiterung der tätigkeit der
europäischen investitionsbank und ein
wie ich finde
aus unseren erfahrungen ja wirklich sehr
wirksames mittel nehme ich die
möglichkeit kurzarbeitergeld zu zahlen
da wo die rücklagen in den
arbeitslosenversicherungen vielleicht
nicht so groß sind dass sind drei ganz
wichtige punkte die sich auch zu
ziemlich vielen milliarden aufsummieren
wenn sie dann beschlossen werden sollten
bei denen man sagen kann das ist
sozusagen solidarität in der krise
und dann sind wir uns auch darüber einig
dass es dann danach ein
konjunkturprogramm geben muss ein
recovery fand wie das genannt wird im
englischen also ein aufbauprogramm oder
ein erholungsprogramm im sinne der
wirtschaft und der arbeitsplätze und an
dem wird sich deutschland auch
beteiligen und ich glaube auch die
beratungen über den siebenjährigen
haushalt finden jetzt unter ganz anderen
voraussetzungen statt als das noch vor
wenigen wochen der fall war
ich wünsche mir übrigens dass man dieses
konjunkturprogramm und diesen haushalt
gesamt bedenkt kann mir schwer
vorstellen dass wir ein
konjunkturprogramm haben aber dann ganz
große unsicherheit wie es dann in den
nächsten jahren weitergeht mit den
normalen finanziellen strömen und mit
den normalen fonds und gerade die
kohäsionsfonds die strukturfonds sind ja
mittel die wir haben um die annäherung
der wirtschaftskraft der europäischen
mitgliedsstaaten zu erreichen was jetzt
ihre fragen nach dem sommer anbelangte
blank ich denke jetzt mal tageweise und
wir müssen immer wieder überprüfen das
ist ja dass wir haben jetzt erfahrung
wie haben die einschränkungen der
mobilität gewirkt das haben wir jetzt
gelernt in den nächsten plätzen
wochen und wir haben auch gesehen wie
schnell das ganze exponentiell wachsen
kann und was das bedeutet hätte wenn das
so weiter gegangen wäre
jetzt müssen wir das konsolidieren ich
nehme das sehr ernst tanner wieder sagt
er redet über entspannung und wenn wir
es konsolidiert haben müssen wir lernen
wie können wir diese einschränkungen wir
wollen ja wieder zu unserem früheren
leben eines tages zurückkehren
wie können wir diese einschränkungen
langsam aufheben wo müssen wir sie am
ehesten aufheben dazu sind wir auf den
rat von soziologen von wirtschafts
würden von ethikern aber eben auch der
virologen angewiesen und da müssen wir
entspannen von zwei bis drei wochen
immer wieder gucken was ist die wirkung
davon bringt uns das wieder an den rand
der leistungsfähigkeit unseres
gesundheitssystems oder können wir damit
umgehen
und eines darf man sagen und muss man
sagen diese regeln nicht die hand geben
handhygiene abstand halten die werden
solange wir keinen impfstoff haben und
solange wir keine medikamente haben auch
vor allen dingen einen impfstoff haben
bestehen bleiben die werden also unser
tägliches leben kennzeichen was das dann
für juni juli august bedeutete das
diskutieren dabei einer der späteren
pressekonferenz
frau bundeskanzlerin nordrhein
westfalens ministerpräsident fordert
jetzt eine offene debatte wie diese
lockerung in welchen schritten geschehen
soll das mache den menschen hoffnung
sagt er und ermahnt dass diese krise
auch sehr große schäden anrichten kann
häusliche gewalt psychologische
beeinträchtigungen und arbeitslosigkeit
teilen sie diese sorge oder befürchten
sie jetzt ein wettlauf um die
exit-strategie unter den ländern und
eine ganz persönliche frage welche
lehren ziehen sie aus dieser jahren
ihrer kanzlerschaft größten krise als
politikerin aber auch als mensch ganz
persönlich also für das zweite muss ich
ihnen sagen es ist noch zu früh
das können sie mich dann mal fragen wir
stecken jetzt er mittendrin in der
anspannung
und die ist schon gewaltig wir alle
wissen noch nicht wie das weitergeht und
ich bin sehr froh dass wir in der
bundesregierung sehr gut miteinander
arbeiten dass da auch vertrauen
zueinander ist ich bin sehr froh dass
wir mit den ministerpräsidenten zu gut
zusammen arbeiten und ich bin besonders
froh dass so viele bürgerinnen und
bürger auch diesen weg mitmachen und
damit anderen menschen helfen dass das
eine grundstimmung in deutschland ist
war die ich sehr sehr froh auch dankbar
wenn weil das liegt ja gar nicht in
unserer hand in meiner hand sondern das
machen menschen für andere menschen und
das ist etwas sehr schönes das zu
erleben
bilanz ziehen wir dann sehr viel später
ansonsten glaube ich sind wir doch alle
in einer so ernsten situation dass zwei
dinge klar sind erstens ist muss darüber
nachgedacht werden so wie wir darüber
nachgedacht haben beschränken wir ein an
bewegungsspielräume sondern natürlich
auch nachdenken wann können wir das
wieder öffnen und ich wäre gerne
wirklich mit freude und die ärzte die
ihnen sagen würde es ist alles wie es
war und wir könnten wieder loslegen
aber so ist es halt nicht und deshalb
müssen wir jetzt in der tat auf den rat
von sehr vielen hören ich habe von
anfang an auch gesagt dass das natürlich
auch folgen hat das häusliche gewalt
dass ältere menschen leiden schauen sie
es darf zurzeit keine besuche in
pflegeheimen oder in sehr vielen
pflegeheimen geben was bedeutet dass wir
menschen dort sterben weil man nicht zu
ihnen kann wenn sie von den angehörigen
entfernt sind das weg sind also die
entfernung da ist das ist doch etwas was
was wirklich bedrückend ist und genauso
bedrückend ist es wenn menschen ihre
freunde nicht sehen können oder
verwandten das ist klar
und so ist doch jeder bemüht
verantwortlich gleichermaßen
verantwortlich zu entscheiden und
natürlich kann man darüber auch sprechen
es gibt nur etwas ich will das sagen als
bundeskanzlerin habe ich da auch bei
allem respekt vor jeder meinung bei
allem respekt vor jedem argument was ja
auch geäußert wird und wir sind eine
freiheitliche gesellschaft eine
übergeordnete verantwortung und die
heißt dass wir aus dieser
herausforderung so rauskommen das für
mich vorrangig das gesundheitssystem
nicht überlastet wird dass wir nicht in
menschliche entscheidungssituationen
unserer ärzte schicken die ich nicht
erleben möchte oder was wir wo wir die
aufgabe haben das zu vermeiden
und diese verantwortung muss mir keiner
abnehmen die kann mir keiner abnehmen
aber in dieser verantwortung muss ich
argumentiere
und so hat jeder auch seine rolle in der
gesellschaft und meine ist an dieser
stelle wirklich auch das zu sagen was
ist das heißt aber nicht dass ich über
das was wird nicht tag und nacht
nachdenke
die bundeskanzlerin herr konnte der
italienische ministerpräsident hat dem
interview gesagt ohne euro oder corona
bonns könne man die europäische idee
vergessen da war jeder nur sein eigenes
würden sie dem widersprechen gibt es
also eine solidarische
krisenfinanzierung ohne diese
gemeinschaftsanleihen
und sie haben einmal davon gesprochen
dass ab 14 tagen verdopplung zeit eine
entspannung eintreten
sehen sie das immer noch so oder haben
sich die maßstäbe da verschoben also es
gibt ja verschiedene indikatoren einer
da ist ist die verdopplung zeit und da
sind wir auf einem guten weg aber man
sieht es eigentlich an allen indikatoren
man kann es einer verdopplung zeit sehen
die viren haben ihren faktor r 0
der etwas schwieriger zu berechnen ist
aber natürlich auch wichtig ist wir
haben das zeichen was heute von mir auch
genannt wurde wenn wir mehr an einem tag
mehr gesundende haben als wir neu
infizierte haben ist das natürlich auch
nehmen weiß wenn das ein trend ist der
sich über längere zeit verstetigt dass
das eine botschaft ist die zeigt dass es
verbessere sich verbessert die tatsache
dass die kurve nicht mehr exponentiell
ist sondern dass die linear ist ist ein
zeichen also es gibt eine ganze reihe
von zeichen und die verdopplung zeit ist
ein solcher indikator das den
italienischen ministerpräsidenten
giuseppe konnte anbelangt ich habe auch
mit ihm vor wenigen tagen lange
telefoniert so sind wir uns vollkommen
einig dass es dringend der solidarität
bedarf in europas einer von jedenfalls
von europas schwierigsten stunden wenn
ich der schwersten und dass deutschland
auch zu dieser solidarität bereit ist
und verpflichtet ist sowohl im blick auf
unsere europäischen partner aber ich
sage ihnen auch deutschland wird es auf
dauer auch nur gut gehen wenn es europa
gut geht dass meine feste überzeugung
und das leitet mich welche instrumente
dafür nun geeignet sind
das kann man durchaus unterschiedlich
bewerten ich sie wissen dass ich nicht
glaube dass wir sozusagen eine
gemeinschaftliche haftung haben sollten
bei dem stand der politischen union wie
wir ihn jetzt haben und deshalb lehnen
wir das ab aber es gibt so viele andere
möglichkeiten solidarität zu zeigen dass
ich glaube dass wir hier auch gute
lösungen finden und es gibt natürlich
länder die gucken schon ein bisschen und
sagen mensch was könnt ihr euch jetzt an
rettungsprogrammen für eure wirtschaft
leisten was könnt ihr für eure
arbeitslosen machen und deshalb finde
ich gerade auch dieses instrument der
kommission dass auch ursula von der
leyen als frühere arbeitsministerin und
ja auch kennerin der situation in
schweren krisen angewandt hat dieses
kurzarbeitergeld eine wirkliche hilfe
für länder in denen die arbeitslosigkeit
jetzt hoch ist und die eben nicht die
rücklagen bei der bundesagentur für
arbeit haben wie wir sie haben um das
kurzarbeitergeld ohne beitragserhöhung
durchsetzen zu können
frau bundeskanzlerin noch eine frage zur
euro- gruppe der vizekanzler hofft ja
auf eine erleuchtung noch vor ostern
inwieweit waren sie mit mark rutte und
mit dem namen makro in kontakt um diese
erleuchtung nachzuhelfen
und welches signal würde es aussehen
wenn auch die europa heute kein ergebnis
bringt naja spekulationen wäre ich jetzt
nicht anstellen sondern die euro-gruppe
hat ja noch nicht mal angefangen zu
tragen ich hoffe natürlich dass sie zu
einem ergebnis kommt und ich war mit ihm
in kontakt und natürlich auch mit mark
rutte aber auch schon zum teil vor dem
vor der euro-gruppe vor der letzten und
ich hoffe dass es zu einem ergebnis
kommt das wäre ein sehr gutes zeichen
zumal man sich sehr nahe ist
frau bundeskanzlerin meine frage noch
mal in richtung zukunft wenn sie sagen
schrittweise lockerung
da gibt es jetzt erste stimmen die sagen
als ersten schritt müssten unbedingt die
schulen wieder öffnen weil das auch für
die familien sehr wichtig sei was wäre
da ihr ansatz was ist der erste schritt
es gibt ja auch den vorschlag des
ethikrat der sagt man könnte da tastend
vorgehen also auch mit versuch und
irrtum manche dinge auch probieren dann
wieder zurücknehmen wäre das was was sie
sich auch vorstellen können wir müssen
miteinander diskutieren gehen wir
einheitlich vor bundeseinheitlich das
wird man bei manchen dingen tun weil
manche vielleicht auch lokal
unterschiedlich weil wir die infektions
lage natürlich auch sehr unterschiedlich
ist ich glaube wir müssen noch das
ausrichten an der frage wo können wir
sehr schnell die kontakt abstände also
die das abstandsgebot relativ einfach
durchsetzen wo können wir das nicht
einfach durchsetzen
wir müssen fragen wie sind die einzelnen
gruppen betroffen und deshalb wird es
wahrscheinlich nie eine 100% lösung
geben in irgendeinem sektor sondern
immer schrittweise kleine öffnungen ich
will ausdrücklich sagen dass ich
überhaupt nichts davon halte zu sagen na
ja die jüngeren sie können jetzt mal
schnell wieder alles tun die sich kennen
und die älteren die müssen noch ohne
kontakte weiter leben das finde ich ist
mit der humanität und mit den
vorstellungen von unserer gesellschaft
nicht vereinbar
wir müssen eine ältere und eine jüngere
und an eltern und an arbeitnehmer und
alle gleichermaßen denken
und jetzt werden wir uns dann das
miteinander diskutieren
ich kann ihnen heute noch nicht sagen
ich halte die schulen so wie man sie
kannte und die kindergärten natürlich
nicht für den ort an dem man nun mit
einfachster maßnahme den abstand
sicherstellen kann
die man noch braucht und dass wir
natürlich auch immer wieder die
wirkungen uns anschauen müssen das ist
ja ganz klar
das habe ich auch gesagt was ich nicht
möchte ist dass wir einen so großen
schritt gehen bei den öffnungen oder bei
den lockerungen sage ich mal der jetzt
sehr harten bestimmungen der uns dann
wieder völlig zurück wirft das wäre doch
das schlimmste wenn wir dann sagen
müssten jetzt sind wir wieder im bereich
des exponentiellen anstieg und jetzt
müssen wir die ganz harten maßnahmen
wieder einführen oder noch härterer das
fände ich das aller schwierigste und
deshalb wird es geduld brauchen es wird
geduld brauchen denn jedes mal mit jedem
solchen schritt das hört sich so an als
wäre das irgendwie eine formel nach der
wir vorgehen können wir wissen das nicht
und jedes mal sind menschen betroffen
hier ist mal sterbender menschen jedes
mal sind ärzte gefordert jedes mal haben
ärzte und schwestern angst dass das
krankenhaus vielleicht zu überfordert
ist und das müssen wir verhindern und
gleichzeitig müssen wir natürlich auch
schritte gehen von denen wir nicht
gleich am anfang wissen was sie bewirken
oder wie es ist und es wird viel davon
abhängen auch bei den schritten die wir
gehen optimierten weiter abstand halten
ob sich weiter die hände waschen ob sie
sich nicht die hände geben und
sicherlich es ist ganz einfach die
kontakte sind ein maß und die art der
kontakte für die frage die sich diese
epidemie ausbreitet sie ist nicht weg
wenn die zahlen meinen tag besser werden
sie wird nicht verschwinden bevor wir
nicht wirklich einen impfstoff haben mit
dem wir die bevölkerung immunisieren
können und das leben mit dem virus also
wenn es ein bisschen abstrakt vielleicht
noch ist leben in und mit der pandemie
das heißt nichts anderes als leben mit
diesem virus das ist nicht verschwunden
auch wenn man sich mal einen tag weniger
leute anstecken wenn sie alle immer so
miteinander stehen wir hier stehen würde
wahrscheinlich das virus uns nichts
anhaben können
das ist die gute nachricht die schlechte
ist wenn man das alles was wir jetzt
gelernt haben und machen vergessen
dann sind wir sehr schnell wieder da
gewesen
danke schön und ich wünsche ihnen dann
unter den besonderen umständen doch auch
noch ein frohes osterfest